this is Sal here and I'm here with Dan
Russell of Google and what we're going
to do in this video is try to search for
things because search in itself is a
skill but we're even though Dan is from
google we're going to be we're going to
be the Switzerland of searchers here
we're going to be searched agnostic
we're going to try it on google and
we'll also try it on bing sounds fair to
me let's give it a shot sounds good and
so the task we're going to do here and
this is a question that is burning in
our brains before doing this video is
who was the shortest American president
I have no idea who is I don't know I
think I know who the tallest is well
we'll look that up to maybe if we have
to go down if we have time so let me say
so i'm naive Sal this is how I think I'm
more statistical we'll see we'll see you
see so let me think shortest shortest us
look it's our today already autocomplete
has that's right that's shortest US
president heights of you ok this was
easy heights of presidents if I can
believe I mean because i can go edit
this this is wikipedia it's raining i'll
look they have a whole distribution here
let's see let's see president ok so the
tallest US president was a but Lyndon
Johnson was closed we always hear about
Abraham Lincoln that's right I didn't
realize Lyndon Johnson I realized Thomas
Jefferson was that tall man jus a grand
jury but there's couple things to point
out very real quick if you go back a
page look at the search result so it's
james madison 500 ok now we answer the
other question if we believe wikipedia
right if that's right let's go back a
page look at the search results page
yeah i'll show you something okay so
that first result you clicked on you
knew is inside the wikipedia right yes
yes it's right in it actually the title
that thing in blue which is now purple
yes because i click actually tells you
that you're looking for yeah it's a big
that's a big hint the next one which you
didn't even look at was a US presidents
my time in office yeah so reading those
little clues is of your big skill oh
yeah just knowing how to both read a
title which just came naturally to me
that's right yeah but you also read the
URL in green right right so that's a
skill because you have to be able to
recognize these things and understand
whether they're credible or not right
and you could you can immediately read
here and you say well this they're using
the word shortest but it's talking about
shortest term of office so you already I
don't have to click on that and who is
and then this is answers com so these
are people asking questions for everyone
who was the shortest and it looks like
you can you actually only have to go
there you can actually while the
shortest was James Madison 5 foot 4
inches the shortest US President 54
inches so you don't actually don't even
have to go to the to the to you don't
have to click on you can just read that
and what is what is being do for us
there ok so if i try to do shortest us
so they actually have an autocomplete to
shortest US president and heights of
presidents it's interesting they gave us
a give the same article so this is this
is wikipedia right there is actually
seems to be very similar at least these
first few other there they are different
the results are different but we would
have gotten the same thing James Madison
five-foot-four it's always james madison
but there's all these different web
pages although this was the same this
was we that's right pd again Wikipedia
Wikipedia often comes up to the very top
of results like right so it's actually i
think a lot more credible than most
people get a credit point right right
now i agree because yes in theory any i
could go edit it and vandalize it to
some right but even that they have some
controls where they lock down to pay and
there's so many people looking at it
that the bulk of humanity which speaks
well or else as a species is actually
that's i do what's right and the thing
to know about wikipedia is even though
you may vandalize it the average time to
correction vandalised pages is quite
short it's on the quarter of an hour to
so even though people go may go and add
mistakes tends to self-correct very
quickly yes actually I do remember once
looking for tallest US president and the
top on Wikipedia was Michael Jordan but
then within half an hour was fixed
that's right it was fixed that's the
kind of thing it happens a lot in
Wikipedia yeah I mean if he if he wins
one day I mean I guess it's not out of
the question but but as a variety a few
transition your as of right now okay
well that one is pretty straightforward
maybe the next video will try something
harder okay